But now where is the prophecy of
Muhammad in the gospel?
>> Well, uh there's plenty of places in the
gospel. Uh in fact, um in the gospel,
Jesus made a a significant uh deferral.
He started off making the deferral with
this passage where he said to the uh
Jewish people, he said, "I have many
things to tell you, but you will not be
able to bear it now. For when he the
spirit of truth shall come, he shall
guide you into all the truth.
And um this is where the deferral began
like Jesus Jesus told them that they
were immature, childlike, they were not
able to process what Jesus was telling
them. So it had to be deferred to a
later date that the spiritual teacher
would come about and fulfill all that
was that Jesus himself was meant to be
fulfilling. So basically um what
belonged to Jesus would be given to the
new spiritual teacher and he would go on
to fulfill all of the messianic
prophecies.
>> Excellent. Can you share my screen?
>> Yes.
>> He's referring to John 16.
>> And gentlemen, this has been great and
energetic so far. Sam, take your time to
respond. Daniel, you can have an
uninterrupted quick response. I've been
drinking a lot of coffee. I'm only going
to be gone for 30 seconds to go to the
restroom. Go ahead.
>> Go ahead. Well, we'll wait. If you want
us to wait, we can wait. We can take a
break. Oh, no. That's okay. I I'll be
listening. So, if you take as much time
as you need to respond, I don't want us
to talk over each other. All right.
Okay. So, you're referring to this
passage, which we're going to now have
fun with because you were referring John
16:12-13.
>> Now, I want you to tell everyone who
sent Muhammad.
>> Can I just make a point? Can I just make
one point, Sam?
>> [clears throat]
>> So you can actually um put out your
presentation without including the terms
or phrases like I'm going to have I'm
going to have fun with it because when
you're doing that you're actually um
instigating me to respond to you in like
manner just make your presentation keep
it respectful and I will do the same.
Daniel, go back and watch from the
beginning. Now we have witnesses as
recorded. Brother, I
>> don't want to go back, but from here on,
can you do that?
>> You started with the attacks and I don't
mind. And I told you, Daniel, keep it
respectful because I'll meet your
energy, friend. Let's not play the
victim, but that's fine. I won't attack
you. But I want you tonight, go back,
start from the beginning. You started
the attacks. I'm finishing them. I don't
need to attack you. So now, let's focus.
Okay, now let's focus.
>> Okay.
>> Now, do you believe according to the
Quran, Allah sent Muhammad, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Did Jesus send Muhammad when Jesus was
in heaven?
>> I mean, I I I don't have a problem with
that.
>> You don't have Jesus send your prophet?
>> No, I don't have a problem with
understanding that phrase. I don't have
the problem with understanding that
phrase because Jesus was speaking on
behalf of God to his people and he said,
"I'm going to do this."
>> No, that's what it means.
>> I know you're trying hard. No, that's
not what he says. He says,
>> "No, it's pretty simple."
>> No, it's not because right here says
here, here he says he will be sending
the spirit from the father. He himself
with the father. Not simply speaking on
behalf of the father. John 15:26, "When
the Advent comes, whom I will send you
from the Father, the Spirit of truth who
proceeds from the Father, you bear
witness about me." John 16:7, "But I
tell you the truth, it is to your
advantage that I go away. For I do not
go away, the advocate will not come to
you, but if I go, I will send him to
you." There is no tap dancing around
this. Just like the father sends him in
the name of Jesus, Jesus with the father
sends him. So I want to ask the
question, do you believe Jesus sent your
Muhammad?
>> If that phrase should be understood
quite literally as you are trying to
present, I don't have any problem with
it.
>> So Jesus sent Muhammad
>> have any problem if if a Christian would
like to think Jesus actually sent my
prophet, I wouldn't have any problem
with that.
>> Oh, beautiful. Because that means Jesus
is your prophet's God and Lord. Thank
you. So aren't you a Christian? Because
no, because you you're impatient. You're
impatient to draw that conclusion.
You're not understanding something.
Because that is because Jesus made a
deferral of his ministry.
That's what it means to
>> I defer my ministry. And he prayed to
God. I defer my ministry. I can't keep
up with Israelites because they're too
strongheaded. I want to do this job with
another spiritual teacher.
>> Daniel, you're lying 16. That's not He's
not telling Israelites. He's talking
about the apostles. I'll get to the
deferral. I'm Be patient.
>> Israelites. Weren't they weren't the
Israelites?
>> I'm going to get to the deferral part.
Be patient. I don't want you to avoid
this part. Just like you don't deny this
part and I will ask the father. He will
give you another advocate. You don't
deny the father is the one who will give
the advocate. In the same context, it is
Jesus who sends the advocate with the
father. They do it together. But I'm
glad you just said, and I hope they clip
this. I have no problem with Christians
believing that Jesus had Muhammad. That
means now you have no problem with
Christians believing that Jesus is your
prophet's God, Lord, and judge. Amen.
That's exactly.
>> I never said that, Sam.
>> I never said that.
>> Jesus prays to God. Jesus prays to God.
All right. Praying to God. And God
approves.
>> And that that's that's what it is. in
order that we're all on the same page,
gentlemen.
>> That's what it is.
>> I I'm curious, father. I'm curious for
myself as well.
>> I'm praying to my father.
>> Am I on mute? [laughter]
Okay. I'm curious for myself and and
then I think we can move along smoothly
this way. Who sent Muhammad in your
view? Uh Daniel,
so the the father himself because Jesus
is asking the father to do it.
[clears throat]
>> Yeah.
>> No, in your view asking the father to do
it. you're in your view it's not the
father so either you don't know the
Quran you're misleading the non-Muslims
because your Allah is a father to no one
so don't tell us the father so unless
you don't know the Quran but you said
you translated it I don't want you to
pull a fast one so I'm going to be
respectful can you show me anywhere in
the Quran and the Quran that says Allah
is the father of Jews and Christians and
Muslims and the father of Muhammad
>> I mean there is no problem in
identifying Allah to be the father of
there's no problem as long as you
understand the symbolism.
>> There is a problem. So now we're going
to change the context. Oh,
>> God criticizes
only when you literally understand that
you know Jesus was a son begotten son of
God having some sort of a biological
relationship that's when the criticism
strong
>> otherwise God would have no problem if
his attribute of fatherhood is uh with
which people you know try to reach out
to him that's completely fine
>> tenants and preach I know your argument
either I'm going to be honest. You don't
know your Quran, but you said you
translate it. Then you're dishonest. No.
Allah is not a father spiritually
either. How do I know, Daniel? See, this
is why we can't get anywhere because you
go into 5,000 tangents. 5:18. The Jews
and Christians say we are sons of Allah
and his loved ones. There was no Jew, no
Christian at the time of Muhammad that
thought that Allah sired them
biologically, sexually. They only meant
it spiritually. And you're God says,
"No, you're not." Why? Because all you
can be is a slave. So again, we're going
to now spend two hours on you just
coming to the point and admitting it.
Can you show me in the Quran?
>> Thanks that you Thanks that you brought
that verse.
>> Hold on. Let me give you the challenge.
Show me in the Quran where it says that
Allah is a father to the Jews and
Christians. I didn't say Jesus. Jews and
Christians that you Muslims are his
sons.
>> Okay. Uh you're making a stretch and not
understanding the verse that you
yourself brought forward. Just show that
verse. Keep Can you please show the
verse
>> that you just brought? Yeah.
>> Yeah. So where does God deny that he's
not the they are not the children of
God? Where does he deny?
>> Really? When it says nay.
>> No. No. You got it. You didn't ask me
that, did you?
>> No. No. Hang on. Hang on. Hang on. Wait.
Let me get a
>> Is that how you interpret it? Is that
how you interpret it? Do I want to open
up the taps for you?
>> Hang on. Don't go to taps. Hang on.
>> Is that how you interpret? I'm asking
you.
>> No mean.
>> Okay. Okay. Now study the verse. The
verse has two clauses again. The Jews
and the Christians say we are the sons
of God and his beloved. And his beloved.
Okay, I'm emphasizing.
>> And then the responses say why then does
he chastise you for your sins? If you
were the beloved of God,
>> finish it.
>> Wait a second. Hang on a second. If you
were the beloved of God, God would not
chastise you. That's what it means.
>> No, finish it.
>> The verse is objecting
of being beloved to God. So then you are
model brother. I think maybe you got to
find a better debater because he said
did you want to finish the text now and
we'll go through now you're now you now
you're undermining Donnie Sam. No, no.
I'm saying Donnie
>> Johnny that Donnie hasn't made a good
business setting you and me up for a
debate here. Guys, don't get me
>> What are they?
>> I'm telling you this when when there is
a second clause of being beloved of God,
then God is saying don't consider
yourself to be beloved. If that was the
case, it would not say, show me where it
says you're not my beloved, but you're
my children. Show me that.
>> It need not speak like that. that it
need not speak to your your level of
thinking, a childlike level of thinking.
God has no problem if if people related
to him as a father. He has no issues.
The only time he has issues is when you
understand to have a biological
relationship with with people.
>> Show me where he has no issues. Stop
wasting my time because you really are
frustrated.
>> This verse says that Sam, this verse
says that
>> God say this. It says
>> God did not negate it. God did not say
hang on some over the audience sake
though I do want to make sure that we're
hearing both sides for our edification
and the passion just shows how important
this topic is so no worries gentlemen um
in my notes the last question that I
think was asked and do you guys feel
like it's been answered show me in the
Quran where Allah is a father to Jews
and Christians
>> is is that what you're answering here
Daniel basically and Sam go ahead
>> I'm saying God does not deny the fact
that they related to him as their
father. He did not deny that.
>> He did not tell them you are not my
children. He never said that.
>> He says all you are are slaves. Chapter
1988 to93. Now show
>> and that's just the fact. And that's
just and that's just the fact. We are
slaves. Even Jesus was a slave.
>> We can talk
a
waste of time, brother.
>> Sam, go ahead. Let's give it to you
uninterrupted. Daniel will throw it back
to you after. Go ahead, Sam. Daniel,
this is your final chance to answer a
question because you're a complete waste
of time. Now, I'm going to ask you again
>> again. You're starting off with a sn
I'm being honest. I could have done
better things. I thought you're going to
be a serious.
>> Yeah, even I was honest.
>> Okay, let's do this just to get back on
track. Daniel,
>> um what we'll do to be fair is feel free
to show Sam in your follow-up answer why
according to him you're a waste of time.
So feel free to refute that or challenge
that based on your follow-up answer. So
Sam, go ahead, reiterate your challenge.
We'll throw it back to Daniel.
>> Okay, Donnie, understand how he just
again did to the Quran what he did to
the Bible. He says, "Allah is not
denying that they are his sons
spiritually. He's simply denying their
beloved ones." So now Daniel, I just
want people to follow your logic. So
Allah can have you as a son without
necessarily loving you. Yeah, that makes
sense. But I'm going to concede your
argument. So here's the argument. They
are sons of Allah, but he doesn't love
them because these are sons he hates.
Okay, I'll go with that. Now, show us in
the Quran where it says Allah is their
father and they are his sons. Cuz you
want everyone to focus on the second
part. He's saying, "No, you're not his
beloved ones. I'll go with you. See, I'm
generous." Now, show us in the Quran
where he says, "And believers are my
sons and daughters."
>> Okay. All right. I'll take my turn. So
the reason why I'm reiterating that you
have a childlike brain is is is this the
Jews were the son children of God,
right? But they got punished. They got
disciplined by God and he sent them off
to Babylon into exile. He also knocked
down their fundamentals and their
foundations with the Romans. Why did God
punish his children? Why? Because he
hated him? No, he did not hate the
children
up until they disobeyed him. All right,
that's when God punishes because of
disobedience. Can the children disobey
God? Yes, they can. So, if we are
relating to God as the children of God,
we better keep the discipline and the
obedience of God. If we fail the
obedience of God, then he will bring
down punishment. And that's exactly what
is being remarked here in that Quran
verse 5:18 where God says, "Don't think
you're my beloved. You're not my beloved
children. You may call me as my
children. If you're not my beloved for
the reason that I'm punishing you for
your sins.
>> All right.
>> Okay. Daniel, I'm going to ask you the
question, but before you answer it, I'm
going to now show you how you really
don't know the Bible, the Quran. But
that's fine. Okay. Now, I want you to
now let me first show you how God
refutes you, the true God, what you just
said. But once again, I'm going to ask,
not you preach. Show the audience in the
Quran where Allah says, "You are my
sons." forget the beloved part. But now
here's your answer. It's because they
are his sons. That's why he chastises
them. So the God of the Bible says,
"Your God doesn't know what he's talking
about." Here, Hebrews 12:5-11.
And you've forgotten the exhortation
which is addressed to you as sons. My
son, do not regard lightly the
discipline of the Lord, nor faint when
you are reproved by him. For those whom
the Lord loves, he disciplines and he
flogs every son who receives. So this
Bible just destroyed your Quran. It is
for discipline that you endure. God
deals with you as with sons. For what
son is there whom his father does not
discipline? And the word also means
chastise. You want me to bring the Greek
weekend. But if you are without
discipline, here's where my God refutes
the logic of your God of which all have
become partakers, then you are
illegitimate children, not sons. The
Greek is you are bastards. Because if
you're truly a son and you do what is
wrong, he then disciplines you because
he loves you. Wait, wait. The ones he
hates or loves.
All right, let me finish it.
Furthermore, we had earthly fathers to
discipline us and we respected them.
Shall we not much rather be subject to
the father spirits and live? For they
disciplined us for a short time as
seemed best to them, but he disciplines
us for our benefit so that we may sure
share his holiness. And all discipline
for the moment seems not to be joyful
but sorrowful for those who have been
trained by it. Afterwards it yields the
peaceful for righteous. So the true God
says on the opposite if I love you and
you're my son I'll discipline and
chastise you. That means your god is not
this god. So I'm going to make it
simple. Show us in the Quran where Allah
says you believers are my sons.
Don't give me a speech. I already
answered it and for the kind of brain
that you have, you are stubborn not to
listen or understand me. So I can't
help.
>> So now D, I got you're the moder. What
do you want me to do? Because this is
how it's going to be for the next hour.
He's not going to answer anything. It's
up to you.